today we're talking about get-ups for
gke and those ready storage and a new
cloud region for Korea I'm Terry Ryan
and welcome to this week in cloud where
we serve you the lowest latency news
application manager is a beta add-on to
google kubernetes engine that leverages
get-ups principles to help you manage
release configurations this cluster
addon pulls kubernetes manifests from a
git repository and then deploys those as
an application in the cluster give it a
try and let us know what you think the
stackdriver cloud monitoring dashboards
api is now generally available this API
lets you read configurations create
update and delete dashboards
programmatically now you can easily
duplicate dashboards across dev and QA
environments or make templates out of
your favorites anthos ready storage is a
new qualification for partner storage
solutions that have met court
requirements for storage recommendations
and optimal on-prem performance these
include dynamic provisioning with
kubernetes native storage api's
automatic storage management across
scale up and scale down scenarios and a
simplified deployment experience check
it out to see if these solutions can
work for you our new GCP region in seoul
is officially open for business designed
to support Korean customers the new
Seoul region is comprised of three zones
enabling customers and partners to run
high availability workloads and store
their data locally if you want to read
more about these announcements or see a
full list check out the link any
thoughts or ideas leave us a comment or
tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you